in the last couple of minutes the
chancellor Nadeem zahawi has said that
he will be launching his leadership
pitch for the top job in two days time
on Monday and has given an outline of
what kind of campaign he will be running
and it does feel like he'll be running a
campaign uh set quite against and in
opposite to the one that Rishi sunak has
set out he is talking a lot about the
burden of Taxation and saying that taxes
are simply too high and as an
entrepreneur and businessman he knows
that lower taxes are how we create a
thriving Dynamic economy I think is a
dig at not just Rishi sunak but
potentially could be seen as a dig at
Boris Johnson as well he says overseeing
the highest tax burden since 1949 is not
the conservative way we cannot tax our
way into Prosperity so I think clearly
he is designing a campaign really to
stand on the other side of that argument
around taxation Rishi sunak very much
talking about kind of fiscal
responsibility and about having to take
care of the the economy um initially
before then looking to looking to cut
taxes after that Nadim zahari also
talking about
um his background
um he of course came to the UK as a
young boy aged 11 and he couldn't speak
English he came from Iraq fled from Iraq
and says that his background there means
that he knows that security safety and
freedom are things that we can't take
for granted and he's committing that
defense spending needs to rise in
response to Putin's War um in Ukraine
also talking about education he of
course was education secretary up until
a few days ago when he moved into the
treasury and became Chancellor in the
midst of all of the turmoil um as
ministers were resigning and he says he
will continue his education reforms and
says that he will protect children from
inappropriate nonsense being forced on
them by radical activists so I think we
can expect maybe in a deem Tahari to be
taking aim at some of those sort of
issues that we know the government have
been pursuing us to try and set them
apart from labor in recent weeks and
months so he is the sixth person by my
account to be in the running
um now in terms of the things that could
hold him back the challenges he may have
to face well I think a lot of eyebrows
were raised in the last few days about
how Nadim zahari reacted
as ministers were resigning when Rishi
sudak when Sajid resigned from Boris
Johnson's cabinet he went into number 10
and got himself a better job he moved up
from education secretary
um to Chancellor saying that essentially
there was a sort of Duty to serve a duty
to look after the country through this
time of course within 24 hours he had
written to Boris Johnson and told Boris
Johnson that he thought he should step
down and he should go now for some in
the party that may be seen as a positive
as a sign of loyalty of not
um sort of stabbing the leader in the
back if you like others may feel that he
didn't almost have the guts to put his
job on the line like people like Rishi
sunak and Sajid Javid you may find that
Nadeem zahari runs into some other
tricky questions
um whilst he's got
um clearly very humble roots and a
fascinating backstory in terms of how he
came to the UK he is a man now of quite
considerable wealth and nothing you can
expect in the same way that there has
been scrutiny of Rishi sunax finances
considerable scrutiny of that part of
nazim zahawi's life as well albeit I
think he has quite a interesting and
compelling story to tell from the
position he was when he came to the
country to where he has ended up now of
course he started and founded the
polling company yougov and was very very
successful in that field